congressional budget negotiators say
they have an agreement in principle to
avoid another partial government
shutdown which would happen this weekend
the debate has been over president
Trump's demand for a border wall we
don't know yet if the president will
accept the deal he told supporters at a
rally in El Paso Texas that a wall will
make their lives better a few blocks
away possible Democratic challenger Beto
Aurore told another rally that the
border is already safe major Garrett is
at the White House with the latest major
good morning good morning the White
House is non-committal about this deal
that doesn't mean yes it portly it
doesn't mean no now those congressional
negotiators were given a lot of latitude
but senior advisors here tell us the
president and his top staff want to
spend today reviewing all the details
that to get things right they say and to
not interfere with the president's
border security message last night in
Texas walls save tremendous numbers of
lives President Trump praised his
long-promised border wall in El Paso
Texas today we started a big beautiful
wall and highlighted the construction of
a 14 mile barrier that was approved by
Congress last year as the president
preached in El Paso we reached an
agreement in principle Republican
negotiators in Congress agreed to far
less in border wall funding according to
a congressional aide the deal includes
nearly 1.4 billion dollars for physical
barriers including 55 miles of border
fencing but no wall Democrats agreed to
drop their proposal to limit the number
of detained immigrants caught in the
United States I will never sign a bill
that forces the mass release of violent
criminals into our country
a proposal that had stalled talks in the
days before this Friday's deadline
negotiators seemed optimistic it's a
deal the president will sign we hope so
but mr. Trump also noted the previous
shutdown the longest in US history was
worth it that was a very important thing
as mr. Trump rallies supporter is less
than a quarter mile away former
congressman Beto O'Rourke a potential
Democratic 2020 contender held a
simultaneous counter rally walls do not
save lives or work disputed the
president's claim that the border
barrier had made a difference in crime
in El Paso the u.s. cities the us-mexico
border are far safer than the US cities
deeper in the interior of the United
States of America
lawmakers have a scheduled in front of
them put this deal together and final
legislative language by Wednesday pass
it in the House and Senate by Friday and
get it here to the President's desk all
that's required Gayle is the president
to say he will sign it a lot of people
hope he does nobody wants another
shutdown thank you very much major